Hello, class. Let's
talk about bones and
specifically about the area
of pediatric orthopedics.
This is Dr. Mitzi
Scotton. I have been a
pediatrician for over 30
years, and orthopedics
is an interesting
subject because of the
differences between
children and adults.
As we like to say
in pediatrics, kids
are not small adults,
and in the area of
orthopedics, This
is especially true.
Children suffer different
types of bone pathology,
and this is largely
based on the fact that
their growth is different,
and this causes them
to have different bony
structure, and because of
their development,
children are at more risk
for injury, but thankfully
recover more quickly.
So our objectives today are
to discuss the differences
in pediatric bone structure
and how this affects
disease processes, to
discuss bone fractures in
children, and how to use
the Salter-Harris Guide for
fractures involving the
growth plate. Next, we'll
discuss the most common
developmental and acquired
deformities of the foot and
hip, and how to diagnose
these based on age and
presentation. We'll review
the presentation cause and
diagnosis of treatment of
pediatric bone and joint
infections. And then we'll
end with discussion of
two osteopathic disorders,
rickets and
transient synovitis.
So upon arrival into the
world, babies have a very
different look to their
skeletal makeup from adults.
To start with, they have
about 300 bones that will
fuse over time into the
206 present in adulthood.
Much like sharks, many
of their bones are larger
percentage cartilage than
bone, and this assists them in
being lighter and more buoyant
in utero, and that assists
them in progressing
through the birth canal and
decreases the overall weight
of babies at birth. As such,
breaking an infant or toddler's
bone requires much more
force than adults, and it's
the reason that pediatricians
are always highly suspicious
of any child *****
when they see a broken bone
in an infant or a baby,
especially those
that are not walking.
This is an x-ray
from a one-day-old.
And you'll notice
segmentation between the
bones of the arm. And if
you look at the pelvis,
it's easy to see that it
looks like parts of it are
missing. And what's missing
is the calcified bone. So
the dark spaces are actually
filled with cartilage.
Since we're not going to
discuss a lot of anatomy and
histology, let's keep those
slides to a minimum and
say that most of the
differences in how we approach
pediatric bone injuries
and disease is related to
highly important growth plate
or epiphyseal plate. The
epiphyseal growth plate is
the main site of longitudinal
growth of long bones. At
this site, cartilage is
formed by the proliferation
and hypertrophy of cells.
The formed cartilage is then
calcified, degraded, and
replaced by osseous tissue.
So damage to the growth
plate can affect the length
of bones, and this can
cause long-term discrepancy
in limbs and is most
affected when they are the
long bones or bones of height.
So take-home message here
about the growth plate
is it is the place where
longitudinal growth occurs.
So let's start out
with some simple
observation on how pediatric
bones are different.
So let's start with
radiologically.
I want you to take
a minute or two to
look at these two
photos and compare them.
The photo, the x-ray on
the left is a pediatric
wrist and the x-ray on the
right is an adult wrist.
And I want you to think
to yourself or write down
what are three differences
that you see just by
looking or describing the
bones in these x-rays.
What I notice is
there's the presence of
growth plate and the
growth plate is here and
here, here, here. You'll
see these lines of
separation. That is
actually where the bone is
growing. And if you
look over to the right,
you don't see a growth plate.
Also, notice how white
the bone is and how
there's darkening on
the inside of the bone.
That's because children's
bones are actually
stronger and have
increased density.
And finally, look at the
periosteum. Periosteum is
the outside covering of
the bones. And you'll
notice that it's thicker
in children than in adults.
So the anatomy and
biomechanics of pediatric
bone differ from adult
bone, and that leads
to unique fractures
that happen in children.
So in comparison to
adult bone, a pediatric
bone is more porous.
It's more pliable.
It's, as we said,
thicker on the edges.
But the good news is that it's
much quicker to heal
than adult bones.
Pediatric bones are
less dense, even though
they look wider,
and they're actually
less elastic, which
we'll talk about later.
They have less bending streak,
and they're less mineralized.
So what do we know about
pediatric bone
injuries? injuries.
Understanding the
differences between
pediatric and adult bones
will help us understand
how injuries are
different in children.
So it should be noted that
after the age of 12 months,
injury is the number
one cause of death for
all children in the United
States, and fractured
bones are a leading
cause of morbidity.
To understand why children
tend to break their bones
more than adults, just
look at their development.
Once a child begins to
walk, they are explorers
and they love to check
out their environment, but
their brains are not fully
developed and frequently
they do not understand
the consequences of their
actions. And this is a
perfect setup for injury,
generally from falls.
As children then enter
their adolescence,
this is a time where
they employ risk-taking.
And so their injuries
may involve the use of
drugs, alcohol, or
motor vehicle accidents.
If you look at where the
fractures occur by age in
children under the age
of 10, most commonly it's
going to be in the arms on
outstretched hands because
of climbing and and getting
into places that are
dangerous. After 14, the
lower extremities are more
involved and the fractures
tend to be in the same
places as adults. Also
tend to be more associated
with falls from bicycles
or motor vehicle accidents.
But bone injuries in all
children, no matter what age,
should be assessed for
what is the mechanism of
injury, and is that injury
accidental or non-accidental?
In other words, is
it intentional or
unintentional? Because
even well into adolescence,
fractures can be
caused by child *****.
so what are the challenges
of dealing with a
pediatric fracture um well
well first an injured child
may be pre-verbal or they
may not have full language
skills and so obtaining
a history and just
finding out what happened
for them to break the bone
can sometimes be difficult
especially if it wasn't
witnessed by an adult
also children are scared
um and and they get
frightened easily, especially
when they're in pain. And
so it's important to always
splint a child who you
think has a fracture or
you know has a fracture
prior to getting x-rays.
And because of the
fact that pediatric
bones are more made
up of cartilage,
the look of the bone
may be different than an
adult's. And so it's always
recommended in children
when you suspect a
fracture on one side, for
instance, if you suspect
a fracture in the right
upper arm, that you also
get a corresponding x
-ray to the other side
so that you can compare.
So let's say you're a
third year medical student
in a pediatric emergency
room, and you have a child
with a fracture that
you've found on x-ray, and
your preceptor says to call
the orthopedic surgeon,
you definitely want to
look smart when you report
out this fracture. So how
are you going to do that?
Well, it's easiest if you
kind of go through this list.
First, where is the fracture
anatomically? Which
bone, which side?
Next, where in the bone
is a fracture. In the
middle, at the end, at the
growth plate. And then next,
if you can, describe what
kind of a fracture is
it. There are several
different types in adults
and in children. In children,
most commonly, we see
something called plastic
or bowing of the bone.
Next would be buccal or
torus fractures, which
we'll go over and show
you a picture of shortly.
Next is a green stick fracture?
And then finally,
is the fracture
all the way through the bone?
Is it transverse, going
straight across? Is the
fracture spiral through the
bone in an oblique manner?
Is it commune, meaning is
there multiple fragments?
And finally, is it open
or closed? Does the bone
protrude from the skin, or
is the skin outside intact?
And all of those are
important because, in some
cases, the fracture
may need immediate
surgery, and in other,
just casting or splinting.
So let's go through each
of the different types
of fractures that are
common in pediatrics.
And these are going to
be the fractures that
you're going to see
questions on most commonly.
So we'll go through
the different types.
First is the torus
or buccal fracture.
And this is the
fracture right here.
And you can see why it's
called a buccal fracture.
It's because the periosteum
buckles out here. And a lot
of times in pediatrics,
when we suspect a fracture
in a certain area, we'll
just find the periosteum and
we'll take our fingers
and run it down the x-ray
and look for any bumps and
those are the torus fractures
it's most common in children
grade school age five
to ten usually they're
incomplete fractures they
don't go all the way through
to the other side of the
bone they're quick to heal
and so for this reason they
can just be splinted many
times they don't even need
to be casted and it can
heal as fast as two weeks.
But you generally want
to make sure that the
fracture does heal. So
you'd want to repeat x
-rays in those two weeks,
especially if you're
still having pain at the
site of the fracture.
And torus fractures
occur because of the
differences in elasticity
in children's bones.
So another common fracture in
pediatrics is the
green stick fracture.
This is what you see happening
to young trees is where
the term came from. If you
see an older tree branch
that breaks in half easily
versus a young twig or branch
on a tree that will not
break completely, that's
exactly what's happening in
a green stick fracture. So
it's either considered
partial or full thickness. You
have partial thickness here
where the fracture goes
through, but doesn't go all
the way out the other side.
This green stick
fracture actually does
go completely through
the bone here.
Again, this is related
to the bendability
and the strength of pediatric
bones. This is a more
serious fracture.
It's going to take
longer to heal. They
take more like four to
eight weeks to heal.
It's always going
to require some
type of bracing or splinting.
And the mechanism to
create a green stick
fracture is greater.
So the force to create
the green stick fracture
is going to be higher
than what we saw for
the porous fracture.
Also, it's most common
in the longer bones.
So an important area of
pediatric fractures are
those that involve the
growth plane. In 1962,
the Salter-Harris
classification came out
to categorize fractures
that go through the
growth plate or involve
the growth plate.
And for whatever reason,
while this is the
minority of fractures
in children, it's the
majority of questions
they like to ask on tests.
But we're going to go
through Salter-Harris.
So if I would
memorize or look at
anything, it would
be this slide here.
So this is a table
that shows the
different types of
Salter-Harris fraction
with a little mnemonic at the
bottom that you can look at.
And we're going
to go through each
one separately
here with an x-ray.
so salter hair is type one
um is uncommon um because
it usually happens in
the area where the bone
where the bone is growing
but the growth plate actually
isn't injured so kind of
counterintuitive um but
it's a fracture through
the zone of hypertrophy um
and so how how you tell
this is you see an increase
in the width here of
the physis or the growth
plate um so you have to
have a really keen eye in
looking for this um you
treat it with uh with casting
or splinting and it's not
common excuse me to have
disturbances and growth
with this type of fracture
um make a mark here because
salter harris type 2
fractures are most common
um so they're going to be
up to 75 percent of the
salter harris fractures
or fractures that involve
the growth plate um and
the good news is it usually
doesn't cause any kind
of functional limitations
um because it occurs
above the growth plate um
and if you look where the
the arrow is pointing this
is the area of fracture
salter hair is type three
this is where you have a
fracture that actually
extends into the growth
plate so you have the growth
plate and now extending
out um into again not not
only through the growth
plate, but this is what we
call the articular surface.
So this is the surface
between the two bones.
And so that type of fracture
brings in a new possibility
of long-term problems,
and that is arthritis. So
if this fracture doesn't
heal correctly and you end
up with some kind of deformity
here in the articular
area, then it's going to
be possible that you have
synovial rubbing and chronic
inflammation and pain.
Typically, the treatment
for this type of fracture
is that it has to be treated
surgically, and these
bones have to be realigned,
and it's necessary to make
sure that this articular
surface is clean or clear.
um salter type here is
four um is another again
intraarticular fracture
it's going above all the way
down into the articular
surface any time a fracture
involves the area between
two bones and a joint you
can have chronic pain you
can have chronic deformity
of the joint and again
surgery would be required.
Salter type three and type four
are much less common
than type two.
And finally, you end up with a
compression or a
crush fracture,
which is called type five.
And again, fortunately, this
is a rare type of fracture.
You have to think about
the mechanism of action
where you're going
to have some type of
compression in this area
that's going to drive
this bone into this
bone, and it's going to
flatten the growth plate.
As it does that, it
actually injures those
cells that are forming
new bone. So this can
be a very difficult
x-ray finding to pick
up on, especially if a
radiologist isn't given
a good history and isn't
particularly looking
heavily at the growth plate.
So there has to be a
high degree of suspicion.
And unfortunately, a
lot of these types of
fractures are found years
later when there's a
problem with growth or
there's chronic pain
associated in that area.
And they'll go back
and they'll see the
remnants of a fracture.
So unfortunately, in
pediatrics, we have to talk
about something called
non-accidental trauma,
which is pretty much
synonymous with child *****.
And if you look at the
statistics as of 2021,
it's very disheartening.
In the United States,
over 600,000 children were
reported as abused. This
included mental, physical,
****** *****, and
*** trafficking,
which is on the increase.
Over 70% of the time,
And that ***** came
from the hands of
someone that the
children trusted,
specifically their parent.
And even worse is that
it's generally the
youngest that are abused
the most. So a third
of child ***** was
under the age of two.
Child ***** is on the
increase. And COVID
certainly didn't
help because it was a
stressful time with a
lot of parents out of
work, home with their
children all day.
When you look at
gender, girls are
generally more
vulnerable and untreated.
And by untreated, I mean not
seeking mental counseling.
Abused children largely go
on to be abusers themselves.
And in the United States,
2,000 children died
from their *****. So
children in abusive
homes are helpless without
mandatory reporters.
And mandatory reporters
can be teachers,
health care workers, or
even friends and relatives.
For child *****,
sometimes you have to
have a really high
degree of suspicion.
I've seen child *****
in families with both
parents being highly
educated individuals.
So it is not based
on socioeconomic
or any type of
other background.
So when do we
suspect *****? Well,
first of all, is
babies with bruises.
Babies, especially
under the age of 12
months, they don't get
out and do much. And
so when they have
bruising, that's typically
coming from someone
else and not them.
Once children start
walking, they're clumsy,
they fall. They can get
bruises on the extensor
surfaces of their arms
and legs. But when they
have bruising on their
back or their torso,
it's much higher
suspicion of *****.
A baby who can't stop
crying, a baby with burns.
Uh, we've seen children
who have cigarette burns,
um, uh, on their, on their
arms. Um, even I've seen
a child with a cigarette
burn on their head, um,
any type of marks
that look like they've
been whipped or, or,
or, or, you know, beaten
with some type of
object, like a belt, um,
children that turn up, um,
dirty, um, or unkempt, you
always have to wonder about
what does their family
living situation look like?
Next is the nervous
parent, the parent that
acts like they're
suspicious and all of
a sudden ready to go
when you start kind of
delving into some more
serious questions.
Any child that looks like
they've been abused, a child
with poor eye contact,
one that's quiet, that
doesn't want to answer your
questions when you point to
a bruise and say, oh, well,
what happened here? um,
or perhaps a child with an
overly serious demeanor. Um,
and then as far as verbal
***** goes, that can
be a little harder to
pick up. However, um,
whenever I see a parent really
putting down their child, um,
at an office visit, it
again, makes me wonder
if you're talking to
your child like this
in front of the
provider, what do you say
to your child, uh,
when, when you're alone.
And finally, young children who
have inappropriate
****** behaviors,
you always have to wonder,
where did the child,
you know, pick up this
particular behavior?
So what are some x
-ray findings of child
*****? The first is
posterior rib fractures
seen here. And this comes
from shaking, from *****,
from grabbing the child
around the chest tightly
and shaking them or hitting
them against a surface.
Next would be skull
and eye injuries
that come from
shaken baby syndrome.
Commonly in children,
when they're shaking, the
weight of their head is, is
much greater than an adult
and their neck muscles are
weak. And so their head
moves back and forth with,
with more of an angle
than, than adults. And so
you get bleeding both on
the front of the skull
and the back of the skull.
And this is just pathognomonic
for or shaken baby
syndrome, and it's called a
coup, counter coup injury.
In this baby, you'll have
to see this is all blood
and swelling. This is
blood on this side as well.
The picture on the right
is retinal hemorrhage.
When you shake a baby and
you disrupt their brain,
that force causes bruising
and bleeding in the
retina, and that most of
the time leads to blindness.
Other suspicious x
-ray findings for *****
is something called
a spiral fracture.
This is the fracture
here. This is a twisting
injury. So an adult twists
the leg of a child and
then something that we call
bucket handle fractures
where the end of the
bone is pulled off
because the child is forcibly
grabbed by the arm or
the leg and pulled and
that detaches the bone.
So let's talk about
something else. Let's talk
about orthopedic disorders
and we're going to talk
about disorders of the hip,
the knee, and the foot.
So we'll start off
with three disorders
of the hip,
developmental dysplasia,
leg cap barthes, and
slipped capital femoral
epiphysis, which you'll
hear called SCIFI.
So developmental dysplasia
of the hip basically is
mechanical instability
of the hip joint. This
happens in babies, and
it's fairly common. It's
happening in one to two out
of a thousand live births.
The buzzwords that you
need to remember for this
is the question is going
to be a female newborn
infant. It's the firstborn,
usually in a breech
delivery where they're
coming out feet first.
Prenatal factors, you know,
might be that there was
oligohydramnios and not so
much fluid before the baby
was born. And potentially,
if this is seen after birth,
then culturally the child
was put into a swaddling
type device, which is used
in some cultures for mothers
to carry their babies.
All of these increase the
chances of DDH or developmental
dysplasia at the hip.
So the diagnosis can be
made just with a very high
degree of suspicion, but
we typically test with
a special exam and by
ultrasound. So you'll see
pediatricians doing this
from the first day that
a baby is born. And we do
several tests to detect
DDH. The first is
the Barlow test,
where we try to
dislocate the hip.
The Ortolani test,
which we try to put
the hip back into
the joint. And finally,
the Glazy test,
which evaluates for current
hip dislocation. The
two tests that I would
focus on understanding the
mechanism would be the
Barlow and the Ortolani.
So if you have developmental
dysplasia of the hip,
what we worry about is if
that hip bone is not located
tightly in the acetabulum,
then the acetabulum is
not going to develop normally.
And what ends up happening
is you will have a leg
length discrepancy. You'll
have one leg shorter
than the other. So it is
important to pick up developmental
dysplasia of the hip.
Many times, this can
be treated by just
positioning the child. And
you'll see left here, this
pavlic harness is one
of the more common ways
that we start. And
surgery is not required.
So the pavlic harness
is here on the left.
It's usually worn for
about six to 12 weeks.
Spica casting can be used if
there's a hard time getting
that head of the femur to
sit within the acetabulum,
but it's used much less
than the papalic harness.
So let's say you have a
baby that you think has
developmental dysplasia of the
hip. You've noticed that on
your exam you have a positive
barlow or ortolani sign
the next test would be to
do an ultrasound and that
ultrasound will show you that
dislocatable hip and then
orthopedics will generally
take over from there and
suggest pavlic harness the
child will wear that for the
12 weeks to see if that will
stabilize the hip joint.
Next is a disease called
leg cab parvise disease,
also known as idiopathic
avascular necrosis of the
femoral head. And it's my
understanding that there is
a momentum going to not
refer to diseases by their
name of discoverer and
more going into what the
actual pathology is. So you
should know both of these.
This has an incidence,
it's much more
rare than developmental
hip dysplasia.
With bones,
DDH is the only one that's
more common in females.
The other two diseases
you're going to see are
more common in males. So
the predominance of males
with leg cap perthes
is five times that of
females. So So if you see
a test question and it's a
female, I wouldn't select
leg-capularities because
that's typically not
how questions are asked.
Usually the predominant
gender is going to
always be within the
stem of that question.
This is a diagnosis that's
made radiographically. And
basically what you see is
you see that the head...
of the femur here basically
kind of wastes away. And
that's the necrosis part.
And the reason that the
necrosis happens is because
it loses blood supply.
So how is a child with
this going to present?
They're generally going
to start with pain. And
interestingly, that pain
doesn't always have to be
in their hip. It can,
it can travel to their
knee, their groin, even
be in the anterior thigh.
After, after pain would
come a limp and something
called Trendelenburg gait,
which is illustrated here.
You're going to notice that
the hip of the affected
side is going to have a
decreased range of motion,
especially when you try
to internally rotate it.
And for this condition,
there's always controversy
as to whether you want to
start with surgery or bracing,
but the goals of treatment
is to relieve the
symptoms and restore range
of motion. So you really
want to rest the leg and
have minimum weight bearing.
Also, wearing casts
or having any kind
of ortho procedures
is very painful.
And so pain control
is important. um,
as is physical therapy. Now
as to the pathophysiology,
um, why, why does the, the
hip suddenly not, um, get
a blood supply or the head
of the femur that is, nobody
really knows the answer to
that. Um, so again, a high
degree of suspicion is
needed and you want to make
sure that you identify someone
with leg cap parthes when
they're in this stage and
not in this stage. Because
once you get a real damage
to the head of the femur,
you're not going to be able
to correct that. And total
hip replacement is needed if
you're not able to get any
type of treatment to replace
the head of that femur.
Now, what they like
to do is try to have
confusion with the other
common hip disorder, which
is called slipped capital
femoral epiphysis.
And so there's a little
bit of difference in
presentation of these two
diseases. They obviously
have a different mechanism,
But when you think of
slipped capital femoral
epiphysis, you think of
kind of this particular
type of child. So this
is going to be an overweight
child at about puberty.
So they're older than
the children who have
leg cap purvies, usually
by three or four years.
This is only two times
more common in boys. So
let's say you have a
question that has a girl with
hip pain and you're trying
to decide between slipped
capital femoral epiphysis
and leg cap perthes.
If it's a girl, I
would pick skippy.
If it's a boy and you
absolutely can't tell the
difference, then I would
pick leg cap perthes.
These children, as I said,
they're general overweight.
They're in a time where their
legs and their
bones are growing.
other in their growth spurt.
And this has a more positive
family history than leg
cap birthies as well. So
presentation is very similar.
Hip, thigh, groin,
or knee pain and
a limp and decreased
range of motion.
This time more with
external rotation.
And what you might
notice is the child as
they're laying on the
bed has their their
leg kind of externally
rotated like at rest
so so what happens with
slipped capital femoral pips
as well as the name says
that the head of the femur
slips off i have this
picture of an ice cream cone
here and this is this is
what happens to the head
of the femur um there's
there's a a place here near
the growth plate where the
slippage occurs um and um
about 25 percent of the
cases can be bilateral and
this is a much higher rate
than um leg cap perthes
leg cap perthes is much
less likely to be bilateral
mechanism or why it happens.
I mean, there's a theory
that the increase in weight
and the sudden growth
destabilizes this region
and the bone slides as
a result of the weight
and the sudden growth.
Diagnosis of this, it's
important to catch this
by getting both an AP
looking at the hip and
something called a frog
leg or the child's legs
are bent, their hips
are externally rotated.
And then radiologists
have their ways of
looking for these
different pathognomotic
signs of slipped capital
femoral epiphysis.
I'm not going to ask you
about these two questions.
If you go into radiology,
they're important.
um so um or slip capital
femoral epiphysis um basically
you've got to get this
this cap this head of the
femur back on and so it
does require uh surgery um
there is some discussion
of whether that you should
do a one screw or two screw
method um and again just
like with um leg cap the
earlier you find this, the
better. Because once the
head slips to the side, you
can actually get similar
symptoms where you all of
a sudden have a poor blood
supply and get necrosis.
And this can be associated with
early degenerative arthritis.
Next, going down to the
knee, something that's very
common, and I used to see
this a lot in my practice
was something called Osgood
-Schlatter disease. And
this is actually an
osteochondritis. So it's an
inflammation in the bone
and the tendon of the tibial
tuberosity. So we're
looking at it right in here.
So you get pain and
swelling in this area.
It's always on the front
side of the knee. It's
made worse by kneeling,
running, jumping. And so we
classically see it in
athletes who are jumpers,
runners, people who play
basketball, cheerleaders,
hurdlers.
And the diagnosis is
super easy. You just
push on this area
right here. And
generally, that will
cause exquisite pain.
And you have your diagnosis.
Generally, I don't do x-rays.
The only time that I
would think about doing an
x-ray would be If the
patient had other symptoms
that would make me think
more of some type of a
pathology, such as an
infection or even a tumor,
which would be fever,
night sweats, weight loss.
um so this is somebody
got an x-ray um which is
good because it shows you
exactly what the mechanism
of a vasco schlatter is
which is that um this
tendon is actually pulling
the tibial tuberosity away
from the tibia as we said
bones and children heal
super fast So this doesn't
take a long time to
heal if you rest it. And the
hardest part of treatment
with Osgood-Slaughter
many times is just getting
the child to stop their
sport for a few weeks.
They do make, excuse
me, they do make these
braces that kind of push
this area back in. Um,
but typically
treatment is rest,
um, ice, ibuprofen.
Um, and, uh,
it is, it is common
afterwards to have
kind of a big bump
or lump right there.
Now we move down to
the foot. Um, the most
common foot disorder
is clubfoot its
incidence is one in that
should be a thousand
not a hundred and again
males are more likely to
have this there is a
genetic predisposition so
it can run in families
and a clubfoot basically
involves not only
the skeleton parts
of the foot but as
actually muscular parts as
well so the anatomic
features of clubfoot
are listed here and so
there's plantar flexion
of the first ray adduction
of the forefoot here
hind parts pointed inward and
plantar flexion
of the hind foot
treatment for clubfoot um
as soon as it's found is
to begin what we call
serial casting which is a
series of casts are put on
the foot to correct it and
guide it back into the
correct position rarely
surgery may be required but
getting getting parents to
get to all the
appointments to all
these casts can be
difficult sometimes.
After the casts are removed,
the deformity can
actually kind of reform if
continued physical therapy
isn't done. So it's very
important that parents
continue to stretch and try
to correct out the deformity
even after it's been
somewhat functionally
repaired with the casting.
Now, this has to be
separated from something
called metatarsis
adductus, which is kind of
where the metatarsal bones
are deviated inwardly,
and its treatment does
not involve the serial
casting. It involves
stretching of the foot.
The parents can do it at
home, and it's basically
involvement just at the midfoot
here. It's not involving
the ankle or this part of
the foot as club foot was.
And if that stretching
and physical therapy
by parents doesn't work
after eight months,
then we typically look
for other potential bony
abnormalities. So just seeing
a foot that's slightly in
turn like this in infancy
usually doesn't cause anybody
to do anything beyond just
the stretching exercises.
So let's shift gears
again, and we're going to
talk about infection of
bones and joints. The
good news is that the
infections of bones and
joints are pretty
similar. They're similar
in their pathogenesis,
in their presentations,
in the bacteriology,
and somewhat
in their management
and treatment.
So let's start with
acute osteomyelitis.
This is incidence of about 1
in 5,000 in those under 13,
mostly younger children.
And there are
some risk factors,
sickle cell disease,
children who
have other types of
chronic illnesses.
The infection usually occurs
at the end of long bones
in the metaphyseal area.
and the most common bones
affected are the femur,
the tibia, and the humerus.
And those account for about
79% of the infections.
And so why do kids
get bone infections?
They get bone infections
more than adults.
And it wouldn't seem
to be that way since
they typically are
healthier than adults, but
their bones are more
porous. And children tend
to have a higher rate
of blood infections
and they have a higher rate of
accidents, which can
increase the risk.
So how do you get an
infection in your bone?
Or AHO, acute hematogenous
osteomyelitis.
Well, that's the most
common way to get it.
AHO is when you have
spread of a serious
infection in the
bloodstream into
the bone via the
vascular system. Um,
that is, is one method.
Another is actually
direct spread from an
adjacent infection. So a
very bad subcutaneous
infection, um, or, um,
uh, joint infection. If
you have an infection
in your joint and that's,
that's chronic, it
can actually infect the
bone next to it. Um,
and also we see people who
have sinus infections can
also have that infection
inside the sinus cavity
get into the bone if it's
a chronic enough infection.
And then finally, we
see injuries where you
actually get a direct
inoculation of bacteria into
the bone from either
trauma or after surgery.
So the development of
osteomyelitis starts with an
initial site of infection,
that infection usually goes
outward. It erodes the
periosteum and you get a bowing
of the periosteum and an
abscess and pus develops.
And then this abscess
forms and it makes
it very difficult to
treat that infection.
So what kind of bacteria
typically cause acute
hematogenous osteomyelitis?
80% are related to
staph, especially in those
over the age of five.
Group A strep is a
distant second, and an
emerging bacteria is a
bacteria called Kingella,
which has been noted to be
increasing over the last
10 or 15 years now when
you look at neonates and
babies in the neonatal icu
they have a slightly different
type of infection in that
they are more likely to
get e coli and gram negative
and different types of
strep species besides strep
a specifically group b
strep and then there's a
subspecial group of children
who You have hemoglobinopathies
that may be sickle
cell disease, and staph aureus
is still the most common
cause of bone infections
in children with sickle
cell disease, but they have
a higher incidence of gram
-negative salmonella E.
coli and even pseudomonas.
So to get the history
of osteomyelitis, it
may be difficult, and
you have to rely heavily
on,
again, a high index of
suspicion. So when we look at
bone infections, they're
many times delayed, pretty
far down the line, and
becomes pretty involved in the
bone before osteomyelitis
is discovered. And why is
that? Again, children are
generally poor historians,
and bone infection isn't
necessarily at the top
of your list when you're
looking at a fussy infant
or even an infant with
fever. But the most
common presenting signs
are going to be fussiness
and the fussiness is
going to involve core
movement of that extremity.
So if we remember which
extremities were
involved, typically that's
going to be the leg. So
the child will come in
mostly with a limp, but
not always. They may just
not want to crawl. They
may not want to walk.
They will develop fever as
the infection progresses.
And one of the pathognomonic
signs of osteomyelitis
is right at that area
where the infection is here
has what we call point
tenderness. So if I push
on this area from the outside,
causes exquisite pain.
If I move down two or
three centimeters below
this, there's no point of,
there's no pain. And so it's
just at this point that
we feel that tenderness.
Again, once that infection
goes on for a while,
as you see worsening
here, you may actually
get redness, pain
over this area in the
subcutaneous tissue, in
the muscle, and even rarely
some redness of the skin
overlying that area.
So in order to diagnose
osteomyelitis, you need two
of the following. You need
purulence of the bone.
And that's diagnosed by
either doing a biopsy of
that area or open surgery
to drain the wound.
Next would be a positive
blood or bone culture.
Localized infection
or erythema in that
area of the bone. And
then positive imaging.
treatment of osteomyelitis
treatment for for bone
infections is is literally
on the order of two to six
times longer than any other
type of infection so for
a straightforward osteomyelitis
we're going to start
with iv therapy for a
minimum of two or three weeks
And generally, we really
need that culture to
tell us if we're on the
right track for treatment.
So a bone culture or blood
culture is very important
in determining what
antibiotic we're going to
choose. We're going to
take our best guess based
on the fact that, you know,
large majority is going
to be caused by staph
aureus. But in today's
world, we have to consider
MRSA, which is increasing
in incidence all the
time. And so this has led
to a change over the last
20 or 30 years in what
treatment we start first.
And that may be anything
from clindamycin, vancomycin,
or even linazolid.
So let's move to
septic arthritis.
So this is a picture of
someone with a septic knee.
uh this would this would
be pretty hard to miss um
and if this child came into
your office you would be
calling the emergency room
and you would be trying to
get that child out of your
office and over to the
emergency room as quickly
as possible because this is
a medical emergency um so
this probably started out
with a child having some
fever uh possibly just kind
of feeling not so great.
And at this point, with
this amount of infection,
and you can see the infection
here, but these are signs
of infection as well. So
this is infection that's
gotten into the bloodstream,
and it can cause then
symptoms of septic shock,
which are going to be low
blood pressure, confusion,
clammy skin.
And so remember,
depending on which joint
is infected, the
presentation is going
to be possibly
considerably different.
Just like in osteomyelitis,
the way that you get
a joint infection is either
from direct inoculation
into that joint or from
hematogenous spread.
The bacteriology is
very similar. Staph
aureus is overwhelming,
most common.
with joint infections you
tend to see an increase
in white blood cell
count earlier than in
osteomyelitis because
there's more blood supply
and it's easier for
that joint infection
generally to get into
the general circulation.
In addition to white
blood cells you can
look at what we call
inflammatory markers
that is the CRP and
possibly the SED rate.
As far as incidence of
where the joint infection
occurs, knee joint
greater than hip joint
greater than ankle joint,
and those three together
make up 80% of joint
infections in children.
um radiologic confirmation
can be important um
joint infections can
be seen typically by
increasing the width of a
joint and so this is a hip
joint infection and all
you have to do is say
what looks different from
one side to another and
here we have nice hip
joint everything looks
like it's in place. And
here we see this widening.
And that's from fluid that's
gotten into the joint space.
Next, we're going to
talk about transient,
sometimes called
toxic synovitis,
typically of the hip.
And it's a disease
that can show up
looking a lot like
septic hip arthritis.
What causes transencinobitis
is not well known,
although it's thought to be
some type of immune reaction
to a prior viral or bacterial
infection. It's most
commonly seen in the ages
of three to 10, which is
when we see the most incidence
of septic hip as well.
And in order to get this
diagnosis, you almost have to
get this history part that
the child had either some
type of viral upper respiratory
or GI infection, um,
at least a week or two
before the child can show up
looking pretty sick though.
They can, they can have limp,
um, and they can have pain
with passive movement of
the hip, but they don't
always have to have limb and
they don't always have to
have feet. So the child
showing up with a joint
infection is going to look, as we
call it in pediatrics,
toxic. They're going to look
sick. The child with toxic
synovitis, they may be kind
of whiny. They may be not
wanting to walk as well,
but they're typically not
going to be as sick looking.
And they're not going
to have the vital sign
changes that you'll see
with a septic joint.
So the treatment is
made by diagnoses
of just the clinical
information.
And it can be pretty hard
to get a parent to believe
that this is something
that's going to go away
and get better because
when children start
limping, it's very concerning
to parents. But you
typically say, go home and
rest. Again, how do you
make a three-year-old rest?
That can be difficult.
You put heat on
the area, sometimes
just massaging the
joint can help.
Non-steroidal,
ibuprofen, plus minus.
We're not really sure what
the etiology of toxic
synobitis is. So So NSAIDs
may or may not work. And
then I think it's always
important because early on,
toxic synovitis can look
just like early hip
infection. So if that child's
not getting better in 24
to 48 hours, you want to
make sure that you tell
the parent to come back.
And the child can
generally return
to full activity
in 7 to 10 days.
so here i just kind of
presented the differences
um they very very well
may likely have a case
of someone with with a
limp um and so transient
synovitis maybe plus
minus fever kind of a
insidious or kind of subtle
onset may or may not have
a limp their blood work
is going to be normal
specifically inflammatory
markers you're going to get that
history like two weeks ago
i had diarrhea or had a
cough and runny nose and
you're going to see normal
x-ray findings normal
ultrasound the bacterial or
septic arthritis of the
hip sudden onset high fever
definite limp limp when you
get your blood work you're
going to have a very high
sedimentation or crp rate
probably don't have the
prior illness, and you're
absolutely going to see an
abnormal ultrasound or x-ray.
So finally, we're going to go
over disorders of
bone metabolism,
and we're going to
talk about rickets.
So rickets is a disorder of
calcium and phosphate
homeostasis,
and generally, we see it
most commonly with severe
prolonged vitamin D deficiency,
and that deficiency may
be related to nutrition
it may be related to sun
exposure but overall that
that problem is going to cause
the bones to be softer
softer and weaker and the
bones are going to bow
they're they're going to bend
and you're going to see this
classic kind of o-shaped
walk that we see in rickets.
And nutritionally, the lack of
vitamin D is the
most common cause.
But chronic diseases
of the liver,
intestine, and kidney
can also cause rickets.
So this is slide. I'm not
going to read this, but I'm
going to definitely suggest
that you review it and
figure out how do you want
to separate out rickets due
to low calcium versus rickets
due to low phosphorus.
Probably remember
that the low calcium
is more common and
it's due to the
vitamin D deficiency
or resistance.
So looking at it from an
orthopedic standpoint,
what do you see again
you see this this bowing
here and you also see
praying of the ends of the
bones and that's that's
the calcium being pulled
out of the bones you
might see something called
the rachytic rosary which
are these knobs here
which again are ***********
of the ends of bones.
So while there's many more
orthopedic pathologies,
this is all we can
cover in one lecture.
And let me give you a summary.
The bones of children are
different from adults,
and this results in
different types of fractures.
And the unique part is
that children can have
fractures of their
growth plates. And those
can be serious and
they can lead to long
-term problems with how
long that bone is or
cause chronic pain or
problems with joints.
It's absolutely critical
when you take care
of children to look at
a fracture and try to
determine is it accidental
or non-accidental.
Disorders of the hip,
common in children, and you
need to know how they
present and the different
types and know who they
present and in what age.
Next, being able to
pick up bone and joint
infections is very
important because both
can lead to a lot of
morbidity of mortality.
And remember that of
the deformations, foot
malformations are the
most common in children.
I've listed the
references throughout this
presentation on each
corresponding slide.
And if you have any
questions, please email
me. My email is on the
first slide. Thank you.